foreign
[Music]
goddamn wind
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure kind of Bus full of prisoners
heading our way got caught in the storm
we need a place to hunker down until
it's safe watch on your best behavior
while we're here
few things straight you're in my house
now I will not hesitate to shoot you if
I have to y'all don't think this is
cruel and unusual right here
you hear that
you tell me how an alligator got in your
damn police station storm brought him in
could be infested with him by now if you
want to survive the night we're gonna
have to find a way to get along keep an
eye on him that's a Bonafide cop trailer
right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
you got one shot Sheriff
I heard it taste like chicken
[Music]